tant de choses se sont passées depuis que je t'ai vu
perdre Miami comme hier c'est assez
frais et puis je suis parti dans un voyage de
découverte de soi
toi et moi nous nous sommes disputés quel nom dois-
je gagner
maintenant je veux facilement sonner juste Oh
[Musique]
comme Dieu est mort un peu renaître à mon
image je pensais que tu serais content de te sentir
petit topper ici et maintenant empêcher
Ragnarok la fin de  tout
donc je monte une équipe
comme au bon vieux temps
le père de la mariée
[Musique]
salut
étant le
combattant on y va
je ne suis pas une reine ou un monstre
je suis à nouveau la déesse
qu'étais-tu encore pour Dieu
[Musique  ]
par la même unité juste quelques imbéciles de chasse
ouais même toute porte coupe-feu rapide comme de l'eau
je ne peux pas passer je pleure tout comme un
feu qui fait rage - j'aime le feu qui couve